okay so i'm very excited for the snyder
cut
it's something i've been covering for
the last three years and just before it
drops i thought i'd subject myself to
the punishment that is
justice league one last time whether
it's the bad
cgi the good cgi what well the plot
holes that exist in it
the film feels like a massive mess of
mediocrity that for better or worse is
now being flushed down the toilet along
with joss whedon's career
the movie was mostly re-shot re-edited
and those behind it were given a studio
mandate of a two-hour runtime
that hopefully the new version will
rectify but is it even that bad
well join me fellow spoiler men and
women as we journey into the annals
and anus of the movie to discuss all the
crap that comes with it
if this is your first time here then
please smash the thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe for videos
like this every week
without the way i'm your host paul now
let's get into why
justice league sucks okay so the movie
opens with what is probably the biggest
cgi blunder of all time
because paramount contractually had it
put in place that henry cavill wasn't
allowed to shave his mustache for
mission impossible
the majority of the time that he appears
in the movie his lower jaw has been
digitally replaced
rather than having cavill just have a
full beard for the film
which would have been the smart thing to
do they instead have the character
looking like a post-surgery burn victim
who's had a skin graft off the arse of
this
movie stuck onto his face it just seems
off throughout but a lot of the time
you just can't quite put your finger on
it however because of that it's hard not
to be taken out of the film
whenever the actor appears on screen
he'll constantly sit trying to figure
out what cgi and what isn't
and it makes for one of the movies most
glaring issues
on top of this is the constant need to
try and divert away from the tone that
was set out in man of steel
and bbs criticized for being too dark
it's clear that the studio wanted to try
and change course so that things were
more in line with marvel's highly
successful mcu
and thus they thought that injecting
bright colour and humor was all that had
to be done
superman appears in a much louder
costume than he ever wore before he died
and to me retcons like this are
completely baffling
it's almost like they think we won't
remember soups just stood about frying
plastic eggs whilst looking depressed
because the world had turned his actions
into political statements
the suit never had the saturation turned
up to 11
and as he died before ever getting a
brighter version this just seems stupid
over the film he could have come back
and been resurrected as a beacon of hope
which would have felt less jarring in my
opinion they also could have explored
how humanity had often criticized him
but after his return they realized all
their wrongdoings
but nope drop that interesting
examination of our culture
and instead just have him go around
filming videos for kids
while spouting off nonsense about how
the symbol is a river of hope or some
crap
and why this is even worse is because
the exact same thing had been done in
spider-man homecoming
months before however unlike that film
justice leagues just didn't fit like
piers morgan at a woman's pride parade
because we'd already seen civil war from
the perspective of cap and iron man
it was nice to have some actual context
to what went on behind the scenes
and it also set up the narrative that
peter was annoying to happy
here you got to see how excitable the
character was at being asked to step up
to the plate
and come the end of the movie you
watched him realize that it wasn't all
fun and games
i have no idea why this scene is even in
the film though
and it's crazy that this is what was
left in especially when the runtime was
so strict
cut to a rooftop and we watched some
pigeons walking around in their own [ __ ]
which feels like it might be a metaphor
for how the execs at warner bros
felt when promoting this movie batman
traps a robber that he's decided to use
as bait
because if there's one thing that batman
likes doing it's putting people in
harm's way
this attracts a parody man who he then
nets up and luckily for him
upon disintegrating it leaves a pattern
of the mother box
now what kind of dumb idiot makes it so
that all their soldiers upon death
reveal their plan surely if you're
making it so that your foot soldiers
completely disappear upon being captured
then it's likely that you're doing this
because you don't want anything revealed
about what's going on
when they're interrogated this would be
like if the soldier in captain america
popped a cyanide pill whilst he carried
around all of red skull's evil itinerary
in his pocket
it just makes no sense and what's worse
is that batman then decides to talk to
alfred
an earshot of the robber he's just
caught not only does he use the name
alfred
we can also hear a top british bloke
talking back
now if i was a criminal in gotham and
heard batman using the name alfred then
the first thing i'd do
would be google that name since it's not
very popular anymore
and i know it's a british person if i
was the robber i can imagine the people
who would fit the description in gotham
to be quite small
after tracking down that one individual
in the entirety of the usa
i don't think that it would take too
long for me to figure out that batman
and bruce wayne are one in the same
and it's a miracle that the dark knight
hasn't been caught yet when he's worse
at holding on to secrets than a
parademon
batman also leaves the robot on the roof
to do what he wants
because what's the point of arresting
people anymore when they already know
your secret
identity cut to a music video and we
watched the nightmare scene version of
joss whedon
reminiscing on his career in hollywood
you also see that in the wake of
superman's death
that everyone is angered to the point
that they're kicking over fruit stands
the world is a darker place now and we
see this exemplified in a group of
bombers
who plan to destroy a building with some
school kits inside
they want to do this to take the modern
world back to the dark ages
so that god-fearing people are something
or more prevalent
and that will stop what's going on with
the world what
no now this doesn't quite make sense for
a number of reasons
and firstly yeah if all you plan to do
is blow up a building because it
represents a symbol why not just leave
the bomb in there
well the movie does sort of answer that
by letting us know that the bombers plan
to go along with it
but this actually causes more issues now
you're taking hostages yeah
which are typically kept as a way to
stop swat teams storming you
and in doing so you have some leverage
to negotiate with
however if all you care about is blowing
the building up in yourself
then just go in don't take the hostages
and just set it off yeah surely that
makes more sense also
why does a bomb like this even have a
countdown timer on it
you're not planning on escaping the
blast yeah
that's absolutely pointless and it makes
no sense
you idiot also yes shut up for a second
yeah
how would blowing this building up send
us back to the dark ages go on
tell me no now i live in england and i i
don't even know what building this is
yet
now that may be because i'm ignorant and
i just sit about watching superhero
movies all day
but even if this was knocked down in a
scheduled demolition
i doubt anyone would even give a [ __ ] so
yeah it makes no sense now
living in england i can tell you that
absolutely no brits
use the term blocks america yeah sure
you can look at a map and see why they
would call them that because the streets
are about as blocky as lara croft's tits
in england though the streets look like
they were drawn by jackson pollock so
they're lying about the bomb going off
and destroying city blocks
it feels more out of place and army
hammer at a vegan meetup
also there's some weird upskirting in
this scene that makes me think
maybe joss whedon isn't the progressive
feminist that everyone thinks he is
anyway
wonder woman stops the bomb from going
off and she saves the day
it's weird that people are depressed
they don't have anyone to look up to
after the death of superman
when the person who's carrying all of
his values and abilities is standing
right there
but never mind now a weird thing about
her is that we see her moving at super
speed
but at no point in any other parts of
the film does she ever employ this
even though it would come in handy jump
over to bruce riding horseback across
the world
and this guy's now got a full-on beard
that's
weird as on the rooftop he said that
they were prepping the jet that night
so either the lad grows facial hair
faster than homer simpson
or he rode the horse the entire way good
thing he's not in a big rush though to
assemble a team
and he can happily just prance about on
a horse instead of using his
jet to land directly in the village
bruce meets aquaman who doesn't seem to
care too much about the invasion of the
planet even though he lives on it
there's also a ridiculous scene in which
a villager steps out of the way of a
wall painting
to show that the mother boxes are very
much part of their culture
and that aquaman is central to it too
you think he'd care
a bit more because of this but nope it
goes down worse than burger king
tweeting women belong in the kitchen on
international women's day cut to the
flash he's visiting his dad in jail
and i think stuff like this highlights
the issue that dc have
unless you're well-versed in the source
material you wouldn't really have
any idea that he was wrongly accused of
murdering barry's mother
and that barry has spent his life trying
to prove his dad's innocence
because warner bros wanted to jump ahead
and catch up to marvel
they skipped over so many interesting
origin stories
and this film has the difficult task of
trying to cram in as much backstory as
it can
the truth about his childhood is
completely glossed over so we can have a
bit about barry
doodling on someone's face and a cameo
by mark mcclure
who really should be featuring in the
superman bits
because he actually played jimmy olsen
back in the day
now he sets off an alert to bruce to let
him know that barry is at the prison
so that bruce can head to his home
surely he could have just gone there at
any time and didn't have to wait for
this notification
as i can imagine yeah if you just walk
in your house
and you find someone sitting in your
favorite chair you're probably gonna
kick off but
but no bruce knows barry better than he
knows himself
now flash in general feels like he's
been ripped out of the joss whedon joke
book of unfunny observations
and he decides to join the team purely
because most of the people that try and
be his friend
end up on the floor when he's rattling
off about brunch
it feels like someone trying out their
first stand-up gig
and the guy is just reduced to doing
jokey one-liners
instead of actually being someone
interesting to watch now we're
introduced to another father and son
relationship
in cyborg and his dad silas completely
gone is his entire backstory and why
they fell out
which involved his mother's death and an
almost fatal car accident for victor
instead we just get that they don't
really like each other and if you know
the behind the scenes stuff then you'll
be well aware that rayfish's role was
heavily reduced
originally intended to be the heart of
the movie cyborg is now
simply a robot it feels like what would
happen if we followed an iron man suit
for a day
at the mascara we see steppenwolf
stealing the motherbox
and for some reason this is in a guarded
sanctuary
that makes absolutely no difference as
the villain just simply teleports it
there's no point in the amazonians even
trying to take it out because
he could just teleport wherever they go
so it feels like an
absolutely illogical action scene also
because the line about there being no
kryptonians on earth was removed
it makes no sense why steppenwolf waited
this long to attack the planet
he's been biting his time for absolutely
no reason and could have just calmed
down at any point
stole [ __ ] without superman being aware
and then tried to take over the world
that way
a steppenwolf was redesigned to be less
intimidating for some reason
and the cgi for him had to be reworked
completely which i think is why this
looks so bad
the guy's seen better days literally and
he's just a generic looking figure at
this point
that feels about as tired as ben affleck
was returning for the reshoot
now we watch the amazonians send a
warning to diana and get a scene in
which we see lois and martha meet
joss whedon thinking that quirky
characters are what makes the movie good
decided to add a news report about a
woman discussing her husband getting an
alien probe of his ass and what feels
like something that might have been
better than watching this movie again
oh matron now i hate how she's seen in
this snarky way
as in this universe people know that
aliens exist
now so why are you looking down on this
woman
diana fell in the backstory of
steppenwolf and we sees he was defeated
on earth before the macguffin boxes were
divided up and placed around the world
now most would have just attacked the
planet again at this point when the
boxes were all separated
so that they didn't have to face massive
armies and they could have just
teleported in and out
job done but not steppenwolf no instead
he's waited for millennia
when he could have literally done
exactly what he does in this movie
at any point before now the forces of
middle earth unite
but instead of getting cool character
development that ties in with the other
films
we just get minus shots of aries and
zeus that make for
a pretty meaningless action scene even
lord of the rings had elrond and
aragorn's ancestor
the latter of which set up aragorn
struggling over whether the ring would
take him too
however this feels pretty meaningless
and could have just been told to us for
the amount that it actually serves the
film
jump to atlantis and we see that aquaman
has changed his tune
and is all of a sudden worried about the
mother boxes after hearing from a sailor
that there's
aliens he heads to the holding place of
the atlantean one
just in time to see steppenwolf stop by
and steal it with no sweat
like prince andrew when you villains
simply can drop in and drop out
there's no real tension to the action
scenes and the character has barely any
resistance
making these moments feel flat i have no
idea why arthur headed to this location
too
as not really being involved in
atlantean culture at this point
you wouldn't know about this place but i
guess i just tell everyone
we also meet meera played by scamberted
i don't know why but
something about her just isn't likeable
in this moment anyway
she does a bit of exposition but we
don't really learn anything all that
important
diana also reaches out to cyborg who
shows up with no questions asked
after reading some text on a screen
cyborg decides he doesn't want to join
them before changing his mind five
minutes later for absolutely no reason
making for a pointless moment again now
i actually like the bit on the rooftop
where they all disappear as
uh that's a staple in batman comics so i
did appreciate the joke
what's that i see can be fair sometimes
anyway
good to gotham harbour and we see
steppenwolf interrogating people for the
mother boxes location
even though he found the hidden ones
really easily
let's break down the locations so you
can see why this makes no sense that he
has to go to people for this final one
when the other ones were so easy to find
now the first mother box was on
demascara
an invisible island in the middle of the
ocean protected by magic
that's so well hidden not even diana
knows how to get back to it
the second is an atlantean tower hidden
so well in the depths of the ocean
that no mortal man has ever discovered
it but stephen wolf can easily track it
down
lastly is the one in the house that he
can't find and has to interrogate people
over to learn where it is dumb
dumb and the fight scene isn't actually
that bad
action wise and it's probably the
strongest part of the movie
however i don't really feel like this is
a good way to show the league's
abilities as a team
and all of them seem pretty useless in
the fight with batman just getting into
a tank
and shooting at everyone there's also a
weird scene in which flash lands on
wonder woman's boobs
and after the same thing happened in age
of ultron it makes me think that joss
whedon might not be the progressive
feminist that everyone thinks he is
aquaman shows about nowhere for some
reason and the fight ends with the
justice league defeated
but in that same breath steppenwolf
doesn't really win either as he leaves
without learning where the mother box is
so all in all it's a complete waste of
time back at the batcave they regroup
and batman has a bit that sort of
character
it made me bloody hate that guy during
it he mocks diana for still pining for
chris
aka steve rodge trev a steve trevor
which one is rich coming from a guy
that's still obsessed over his parents
deaths
and b isn't something that he would say
because of the last point
batman is someone that has dealt with
grief his entire life
and for him to be mocking a person who
lost the love of their life during a war
it just seems like something a sociopath
would say
the guy has spent the entire movie
trying to unite the team
and this line is something that's always
stuck out to me as being completely
terrible
also why is batman so desperate to
resurrect superman
he's seen firsthand that doomsday is
certainly something that could happen
but instead he just puts his foot down
and decides that this idea is the best
plan they have
next we cut to an even more awkward
scene that shows flash in cyborg
digging up clark's body now something
that seems stupid here is that flash
could do this in the blink of an eye
but rather than speeding through it and
getting the body out of there instantly
they'd rather just do it as slowly as
possible jump to the kryptonian ship
and we see them trying to resurrect
clock there's no power but for some
reason i think that if flash just runs
out the motherbox
it'll charge very fast glad glad we're
following the rules of signs here we
also see the photo of jonathan that
clock was buried with
get dunked into some water because they
don't really view clock as a person
just a weapon to fight with complete
disrespect
superman comes back to life and from
here we watch the fight outside
this was originally meant to be at night
but everyone knows a good movie is based
solely on what time of day it is
so the studio changed to today time
because marvel marvel marvel
because they need a reason for them to
go head to head cyborg's arm cannon
attacks him
and the group have a scuffle that shows
when it comes to head butting
that superman is an equal opportunist i
do like the eye bit though
good bit that so let's keep watching
this movie
now evan shows up and then we get one of
the worst callbacks to any movie ever
was it was great the first time around
but here it just feels like a meme
because of this bit rather than it being
a badass moment
it's reduced to us just staring at that
botched botox that has been done to
henry's lips
that makes him look like leslie ash in
the 90s now
i wish that he they just said martha or
something
and even though i don't really like that
line that much since amy adams has
absolutely nothing to really do in the
movie
they've decided that she's now the big
guns and she's brought into the battle
because
as we know bruce doesn't mind putting
people in danger
now first off how does he know that
supes won't completely rip a report
i mean up until this point he's been
head-butting women so i don't really see
why this would be
any different secondly how do you even
explain to her that you're trying to
bring a boyfriend back to life
and you just need her to wait in the car
on the off chance that it might not work
luckily it does yeah but we get another
facepalm moment when we learn the league
just left the mother box lying around
and this steppenwolf can come in and
steal it seriously
these are earth's best protectors yeah
are these the guys who are relying on
saving us
what a [ __ ] show now on the other side
of this is the russian family that we
follow throughout
for some reason they thought it would be
a good idea to waste time on nameless
characters that we know nothing about
who pretty much pop up in the film to
show us things at steppenwolf space
however when these characters are
reduced to being nobodies
makes it difficult to care so you're
left with a big chunk of the movie that
could have been removed without losing
any of the plot they're not big name
actors don't have any charisma sorry
guys
unfunny and also don't have any
emotional moments
so spending any time with them is
completely pointless
back at the bat cave bruce asks aquaman
to put some feelers into the ocean
and this pun is so bad it must have
given the screenwriters hemorrhoids
trying to push this [ __ ] out
the last thing about this entire scene
they're better because
it's a complete mess most of the time in
movies like this
we sort of get a triumphant moment where
the heroes realize that
if they work together they can do it
it's inspirational and drives home the
sacrifice that they're willing to give
however here they all just think they're
gonna die and so
you feel pretty deflated heading into
the ending and what an ending it is
for some reason this entire scene feels
like it was mastered by someone
colorblind
and leads to the worst looking set piece
that i've ever seen
the entire thing looks like a bag of
malwa and at one point batman blasts his
way through his shield
which has about as much purpose as the
russian family every shield can be
destroyed this easily yeah and it's not
much of a shield
and it's just head scratching why i
thought to put this in
anyway inside the dome we watch our
heroes get annihilated by steppenwolf
again
but luckily superman 64 shows up and he
saves the day
another thing in this moment that i
can't understand is why they cgi'd out
batman's goggles on his head
there was no reason to do this at all
and just feels like they focus so much
on removing the my new details that they
forgot about the bigger picture
now rather than staying behind to stop
the mother boxes from destroying the
world
supes decides to fly off and start
saving people
because for some reason there's always
been something that says if superman
isn't out saving people then he's not
superman
it's a critique that's been lobbied
against a lot of these movies but
to me it makes a little sense because
surely he's saving them by stopping the
villain
but never mind he has to fly off because
of reasons
and the league struggle with steppenwolf
once more even though superman could
kick the crap out of him
also yeah if you picked up a building on
its side right yeah
it wouldn't look like this mate i tell
you it wouldn't lie flat
like that but you know i i don't really
i don't i don't even care at this point
now eventually
the league managed to stop steppenwolf
by smashing his axe
and this defeats him because he feels
scared or something
we don't know if he lives or dies but
maybe they should have just done this at
the start
and then we could have saved 30 minutes
anyway flowers sprout
up from this for some some reason and
then everyone returns to normal with
clark kent coming back from the dead
without any questions being asked the
power's credit scene has a cool little
call back to the comics with superman
and flash racing
but again the cgi is so bad it's
difficult not to think
what the [ __ ] is going on at this point
the second one features everyone's
favorite version of lex luthor being
deathstroke for the legion of doom film
that because of this movie will probably
never happen
it's a big waste of time bigger than
this video but hopefully you've enjoyed
me discussing why justice league sucks
let's forget this never happened and
hopefully this snyder cut will be better
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you drop them in the
comments below
and as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be ending into a prize
through on the 31st of march
in which we're giving away three copies
of a marvel 4k boxer of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with exactly what
you think
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
all the easter eggs in one division
which will be linked on screen right now
about 35 minutes long it's probably
boring as hell but you know we point out
some cool deals so definitely
check it out after this by the way thank
you for sticking through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace